family friends and even strangers
gathered at a long island funeral home
sunday to celebrate the life of gabby
petito she was found dead in wyoming a
week ago and her fiance is still the
focus of a nationwide manhunt mary
murphy reports it's not fair her family
deserves to lay her to rest the right
way alexis trauma went to middle school
with gabby petito who was celebrated at
her memorial for her sense of adventure
even as her remains are still in wyoming
where she was found in the forest a week
ago yet there was a huge outpouring of
love in the county where she began her
van life journey in july with so much
hope and excitement her on the lam
fiance and traveling companion now the
person of interest in her death there's
a trip that you guys want to take
take it
now do it now while you've got the time
if there's a relationship that you're in
that might not
be the best thing for you
leave it now more than half a billion
people followed the search for gabby
petito on tick tock and other platforms
with video of her white van discovered
by one vlogger likely leading to the
discovery of petito's remains she had
stopped communicating with her family in
late august the search for fiance brian
laundry was focused on a massive florida
reserve petito's great aunt liz spoke
outside the memorial i almost don't even
have words it's just so heartbreaking
what happened to her and and
we love her and we know that she's at
peace right now an empty urn sat on a
stanchion at the memorial we are told
gabby petito's remains could be released
to her family this week she will be
cremated such a sad ending for a vibrant
young woman called the beautiful light
by all who knew her
in suffolk county long island i'm mary
murphy